[Music]
there's several ways to approach stoic
theory but i think one of the best ones
is to look at stoicism in terms of two
fundamental pillars one of which is that
we should live according to nature
now as soon as i say that uh people
started stripping naked and running to
the woods and you know hugging trees and
things like that
fine you can do that but that's not what
stoicism is about i'm sorry to
disappoint what it is is is this the
stoics figure look if the if the
question is how do i live a good life as
a human being then i have to answer
another question what the hell is a
human being
because if i don't understand human
nature then i'm likely to mislive my
life to make wrong decisions about my
life
think about this they thought about
human beings as any other living
organism if somebody comes to your home
and gives you a cactus for instance you
have to ask yourself what is a good life
for a cactus
and you better answer correctly
otherwise that cactus is going to die uh
over the next few days because you're
either giving too much water or not
enough light or you know things like
that now human beings are a little bit
more complicated than cacti but not that
much
and according to the stoics there are
two things that are really fundamentally
important for human beings other than
the basics i mean we like every other
animal we need to eat and sleep and you
know have sex all that sort of stuff
that's fine but that's we share that
with a lot of other animals so it's not
distinctive of human nature it's just
what we have in common with as animals
what is distinctive of human nature
according to the stoics at least are two
things
we can think
and we're very social
so we tend to solve our problems by
thinking about stuff reason is the way
we we
navigate life
compared to other animals we don't have
strong muscles we don't run fast we
don't fly we don't have fangs nothing
like that but what we do is we solve
problems by using our large brains
so reason is a fundamental component of
a human life the other one is society
we're not the only social animals of
course these are bonobo chimpanzees some
of the closest relatives that we have
we're certainly not the only social
animals but we are incredibly more
social than anybody else our societies
are much more structured much more
complex much more interdependent uh than
any other animal society so the notion
is well if this is what what it means to
be human then it follows that a good
human life will focus on using well
these two characteristics so to improve
and use your reasoning abilities is a
one important path toward a better life
and to improve your social relations
is a good way to live your life so
living according to nature just means
think about your stuff solving problems
and be as social as you can
the second pillar of stoic philosophy is
something that is uh often referred to
as the dichotomy of control although the
word control as you'll see
uh it's actually a little bit
problematic because it immediately uh
leads it leads itself to
misunderstandings maybe we're going to
talk about it a little a little later
but fundamentally the academy of control
is this notion that some things are up
to us and other things are not up to us
meaning that the buck stops with us on
certain things we are responsible for
certain things and for other things we
are not ultimately responsible and that
a good life is one in which we focus on
the first
and tend to ignore the rest
or accept the rest as it is now this is
not just a stoic idea it comes up in
8th century
buddhism in 11th century judaism and in
20th century christianity you might have
heard of the serenity prayer serenity
prayer asks which was written by an
american theologian early part of the
20th century and asks god to give us the
wisdom to tell the difference between
what we can change and what we cannot
the courage to change what we can and
the serenity to accept what we cannot
that's pretty much the economic control
and in fact it's not by chance that you
find it in christianity because the
christians got it straight from the
stoics
here is epictetus
on the economy of control this is the
way he explains it he says
some things are up to us while others
are not up to us are opinion motivation
desire aversion and in a word whatever
is our own doing
not up to us our body property
reputation office and in a word whatever
is not of our own doing now these words
are the first group is a little
misleading because when it's translated
in english
like desired are that my desire is
really up to me but in fact if you look
at the greek words it's much more clear
what it means essentially what
epithelius is saying here is that the
things that are really up to me are my
own considered judgments if i make a
decision about something if i have a
conclusion that is my own conclusion i
can't blame other people i can say yeah
i was influenced by this or that or the
other i read this or that or the other
but ultimately it is my judgment and my
own decision i'm responsible for it
the values that we endorse
right if we agree on something or
disagree on something we think that
something is important or not important
that's also us we can be influenced
again by others but ultimately it comes
down to our decision and our decisions
to act or not to act
okay when if i decide to come here and
you know in london despite a pandemic
and all that so that's my decision i
can't blame anybody else okay if i get
sick because of covet i'm i'm the one to
blame
i can't say oh well but you know there
was other whatever it doesn't matter i
made the decision so it's up to me right
notice what is not up to me
pretty much everything else
body meaning your health
property your wealth and possessions
reputation
office meaning your career
now of course we all think well wait a
minute but i can definitely influence
all those things
yes you can but ultimately the outcome
does not actually depend on you it's not
on your control
take body because we're invisible
pandemic as an example right so what is
up to you in the middle of pandemic well
to understand what a pandemic is and
what a virus is that doesn't mean you
need to become an
epidemiologist or a virologist just a
minimum you know at least wikipedia
level understanding of these things why
because they inform your decisions
uh you can decide to get vaccinated as
soon as the vaccine is possible to wear
masks when it's not necessary to
maintain social distance to keep washing
your damn hands every five minutes you
know that sort of stuff
those are up to you
but those
fall into these things those are your
judgments your decisions to act or not
to act your endorsed values
whether you get sick or not does not
depend on you because believe me i'm a
biologist viruses are sneaky damn things
you can do everything right and still
get sick
of course if you do everything right
you're far less likely to be sick right
so you influence the outcome but you
don't determine it and so for a stoic
you need to focus on the first part
make the right decisions understand the
situation and then live with whatever
consequences come out because the
consequences are not up to you
that's the dichotomy of control
now cicero not a stoic but a philosopher
a
academic skeptic was his philosophy but
a philosopher who
was definitely sympathetic to the stoics
and actually a lot of what we know about
stoicism comes from cicero came up with
this really interesting analogy to
explain the economic control
he said
if a man or woman or whatever you know
update the language to the 21st century
where to make make it his purpose to
take a true aim with a spear or arrow at
some mark
like this guy over here
his ultimate end would be to do all he
could to aim straight whereas the actual
hinting of the mark would be in our
phrase to be chosen but not to be
desired in other words what you're doing
in life is you act like a archer the
archer has under his own power to
select the bow and the arrows to take
care of them to practice archery to
focus during the actual shot and then to
decide the moment to when when it is the
moment to let the arrow go that's it
as soon as the arrow is gone
all sorts of other things can happen the
enemy soldier can turn the last moment
see it duck it and done
thus the wind comes in and ruins the
best shot the outcome is not up to you
but the preparation and the intentions
are up to you
and so the notion here is basically that
you should internalize your goals
focus on what is up to you and then
prepare to accept the outcome
regardless of what it is
that applies
everywhere um career relationships stuff
like that so let me give you a couple of
examples so suppose that you tomorrow
you are up for a job interview
it comes natural to us to focus on the
outcome will i get the job or will i not
get the job but according to the stoics
that's exactly the wrong focus because
getting the job is not up to you it's up
to whoever interviews you it depends on
factors that are not up to you like your
competition
what is up to you
is to put forth the best resume possible
for that particular job
to uh focus during the interview to
dress appropriately and show up on time
at the interview or try to show up on
time interview in the interview because
you know if there's too much traffic or
the the tube is not working then that's
not up to you either
uh not going out uh with friends
drinking tonight because you know that's
probably going to interfere with your
sleeping patterns and therefore tomorrow
you're not going to be doing a good
interview so those are the things that
are up to you the outcome is not
relationships again comes now just say i
want him or her
to love me to be etc
wrong that's up to them not up to you
what is up to you is how you behaved
over them right you be you focus on your
part being a loving person understanding
being around that sort of stuff then
it's up to the to your partner whether
they reciprocate or not to what extent
they reciprocate or not and so on and so
forth right
now if you do that epictetus makes a
really big promise he says that you be
happy and serene he says if you have the
right idea about what really belongs to
you meaning what is up to you and what
does not meaning what is not up to you
you will never be subject to force or
hindrance you will never blame or
criticize anyone and everything you do
will be done willingly
because everything you do you try to do
is under your control the outcomes are
not but your decisions are and so you're
not going to blame anybody else you're
going to be fine serene and accepting
ideally accepting the outcome of course
it takes
practice to get to that point but that's
the idea
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas